welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Nargis urami an assistant professor
of anthropology at Yale University
professor irani primarily works on the
relationship between economy and
religion and how it's played out in the
rituals of everyday life her work is
centered in the holy city of Goa in Iran
professor Ramiz work includes a
historical and ethnographic study of
carpet merchants and she is currently
researching the cultural production of
authority and knowledge through
publications of Islamic texts and their
global circulation today we'll talk with
her about her forthcoming book on the
Persian rug bazaar
welcome professor irani Thank You
Marilyn for having me let's begin with
an overview of your book tell us about
it
well my my book comes out of my
dissertation primarily where I spend two
years two continuous years doing
fieldwork in the holy city of Qom and
working primarily with carpet merchants
carpet producers and the entire carpet
community in the holy city of home and I
concentrate on the relationship between
the bazaar the market as it is known in
Persian and the merchants the community
in its own so women men and all that who
are involved in the community and the
way carpets as a local yet global
commodity interplay in everyday life and
I look at carpets as as an art as well
as a sort of art in as a commodity form
and commodity as an art form so I look
at the way that the designs of the
carpets affect everyday life and how
everyday life affects the designs of
carpets how did you become how did you
come to write the book well I was born
in the holy city of Qom and to to a
carpet merchant families so why became
interested in in writing about the book
was that when I was an undergraduate I
started to read about Iranian history
and and one of the things that I would
continuously read especially this is
this is in the 1990s and I would read
about the Islamic Revolution that
happened in 78 79 and I was still young
but I was still living in Iran at that
time and so I would hear about and
reading about it as an undergraduate I
would hear about the the fact that there
was this natural almost organic
relationship between merchants known as
Bazar ease from the people from the
bazaar and the clerics and this sort of
natural relationship was taken to be a
sort of a fact and and that in terms of
as a given between power a power of the
state and the people and this
relationship brought together the Bazar
ease against the the Shah at the time
and so coming from a merchant family and
and again simultaneously I would read
about the holy city of Qom
as this sort of opaque place a
mysterious place highly exotic eyes not
just outside of Iran when I was going up
in California amongst the Diaspora the
Iranian the larger running community in
Southern California where I would feel
reticent to say I was born in calm and
so I started to but why why would you be
afraid to say that because at the time
the you know so this was in the 1990s I
had I had grown up in in Iran till I was
about 7 years old and had moved to the
United Arab Emirates and I was living in
Dubai where I would feel a hint of that
living in Dubai but it was really in the
in the United States
amongst the Iranian community the
Diaspora community that I would feel
that there was this tension between what
the Islamic Republic at the time and
what it stood for and
the Iranians who felt that they were
pushed out of the country because of the
clerics in charge and the holy city of
home is Iran's arguably most religious
city it is known as a seminary City so
all the clerics took power at one point
have studied in home or know each other
from mom or hold offices in Guam or
actually live in home and so Ayatollah
Khomeini held a house there and he was
under house arrest later on and had to
leave the country in exile and he is the
he's the founder of the Islamic
Revolution considered a sort of the
father of the Islamic Revolution and the
the people in the city of home were
known to be active in making the
Revolution and they were and it's the
city is sort of known for the Kindle
that started the revolution and and I
grew up being from my father's side who
my father is from there his family's
from there and they continued to live
there I grew up having a very different
view of the holy city of home I I
thought of it as I had wonderful
childhood memories of going to the Mosul
and there is a female Saint the sister
of the 8th mom who's buried there it's a
pilgrimage city since the 9th century so
I grew up thinking of it as a wonderful
space and though I knew that I soon
found out that it represented something
very negative for most Iranians living
living abroad especially and even
Iranians after I went to do research in
Iran even for many Iranians living in in
Tehran especially that this was a place
that was in some ways anti-women
because even though now it is obligatory
for women to wear the hijab and be
covered in in Iran under under the the
law in the city of home even before the
Revolution where this law did not exist
you had to wear the hijab it was
enforced by society
it was enforced by the fact that it was
a seminary City and it was a pilgrimage
city and
out of respect folks where women were
were the head job but also men would
conform to to be a little more
conservative in the way they dress in
the way they acted let's talk about the
methodology you used to write the book
how did you do your research well I had
the advantage of being from a merchant
family and Missouri's tend to be and
this is in some ways a stereotype but a
stereotype that worked in my favor they
tend to not want to let people know
about their business so I would I had
access to accounting books that was one
of the resources that I tapped into so I
would start with my own family and then
I had folks in my own family introduced
me to other folks in the bazaar and then
I was I had access to something that was
not rarely available if I went to that
say it was ours you know the markets in
other cities so let's say if I would go
to two bazaars in Teheran I would be
able to go into someone's store and
start to interview them but I wasn't
always able to get an invite into their
families homes and in-home I was able to
do that and after spending a long time
in the bazaar and of course people
remembered me being there when I was a
little girl so it allowed me to enter
their lives quite easily even though
they were very much aware that I was
doing research and I discovered that
there is this entity that was really
created after the Revolution for members
of the bazaar to be able to deal with
their problems it's it's called a net
tahadia which is basically a guild like
institution and and so there is a
Natalia for almost every vocation in the
bazaar in every city but some of them
are more important than others and there
they would have these meetings and
sometimes I wasn't allowed to go into
the meetings but my tape recorder was so
my presence as a female as an outsider
was not permitted by the tip but that my
tape recorder was so I was able to get a
very good ethnographic feel for what was
going on from the bazaar and then
into into their family homes how many
families are in the bazaar many
merchants are there and I assume they're
all family run they're all family run
it's very much so one of the reasons
that carpets become important is that it
has a historical presence that's it it's
it's well let's put it this way it's
historically imbued with power and art
and craftsmanship and nationalism and at
the same time I'm also concentrated on
carpet merchants and as I was saying
before when I would read Iranian books
on Iranian history the the relationship
between power and and States as seen in
the form of the bazaar is in the
relationship between these merchants and
the clerics we're sort of given
obviously merchants would give based on
religious tithing would give certain
amount of money to clerics and they're
always these ties but from from my
perspective I wanted to not see it as a
given I want to actually describe this
relationship so I realized that when
when historians would refer to Bazar
ease there were all sorts of levels of
buzzers or the very wealthy was or is
there a sort of medium level missouri's
and based on their vocation they were
they were they were located differently
in the actual bazaar which is you know
the bazaars are kind of where we get our
modern malls the the sort of covered
walking places and so where you were
located in in the Bazar which is sort of
how it is now even where you're looking
in the mall really says about the kind
of consumer that comes in and so it
dictates the the your importance in some
ways within the community and bazaars
are centrally located in towns in in
Iran and and so I became sort of
fascinated with with the way these
merchants were able to with carpet
merchants and I was very much interested
in carpet producing merchants so as
opposed to carpet sellers who you see
let's say all over the US I became very
interested in carpet producers because
they
no rugs intimately they are the
tastemakers they are the designers and
they work a little bit like film
producers they bring all these different
actors together but but this guilt that
I was referring to all these different
actors so designers weavers they were
all part of the skilled and they've all
made up the larger community and so part
of what I was doing was doing
ethnographic fieldwork it's just a sort
of spending time in the bazaar with them
and moving from place to place as they
moved and then the other level was
studying the design and doing an
ethnography of design of the actual
carpets so I would look at the carpets
also as a kind of document as a kind of
piece of movable history and I would
read the design and the thought behind
the carpets in terms of how it affected
of course the the the carpet merchants
and the way the processes that would go
into selling it or selling it overseas
which is what primarily most of the rugs
that are made in in the city of Qom made
more than 90% of it are for export ok
and that brings me to a term you use the
colonization of taste what do you mean
by that well the concentration of taste
is a term I use in in the book in order
to basically understand how the
merchants felt throughout history in a
way the way carpets were portrayed and
who their consumers were so carpets are
introduced to the Western world through
the Dutch paintings of the 16th of 1516
16th and 17th centuries and they were a
particular design and so they they later
on a germ some German but mostly French
and English travelers were fascinated by
corporate merchants and already by the
19th century they thought that the
originality had had basically died in
Iran and that the the sort of the zenith
the height of wonderful carpets from
myth
Tyrael to design to color really was in
the 16th and 17th century and what they
were witnessing in the 19th century was
already the end of the carpet the the
quality of carpets and the designs and
so why is that well there were multiple
factors of course one of the reasons was
that the carpet merchants were moving
away from sort of natural dyes and
moving into chemical dyes in order to
come up with more intricate colors other
reasons were the movement of well the
one was the material also there was a
there this the the wool and the carpet
that was used there the quality of the
material had had decreased greatly the
the secondary reason is that the the
designs seemed more repetitive and there
was there was a movement also to kind of
control this and again as carpet still
tend to be there the second largest
export out of Iran after oil and they
are still the only industry that is
completely cottage industry run by
merchants and their families and they
see the weavers as an extension of their
families and sometimes at different
times of state and then again
foreign powers were trying to control
the carpet industry in in different ways
and in the in the early 20th century you
begin to see American companies moving
into Iran and they were interested in
controlling the carpet industry by
controlling the quality of the colors
the quality of the actual carpets and
how straight they were the designs and
coming up with pushing pushing the
merchants not to force the weavers into
coming up with designs that they thought
were what Europeans wanted or what other
folks wanted but really what classic
designs were so pushing them back to
16th and 17th century designs as opposed
to
new designs or innovative designs that
they were interested in doing and so so
that's the sort of historical crate for
this conversation of taste and how does
your research differ from from the other
work that's out there well um I look at
the relationship I feel as if you can't
just look at the carpets there there are
works done on carpets and mostly sort of
in terms of aesthetics I I think that
it's important to look at the carpets as
as design as a commodity as an art form
and then also look at its circulation
but also look at the merchants who
produce it so I look at production and
consumption as opposed to one or the
other and I also look at the
relationship between the merchants the
weavers and the families and on carpets
and one of the and so all those things
haven't been done together and the other
element is that carpets are a toxin s2
so to where they're from so it's
important to know that this carpet is
woven in Isfahan designed in Isfahan
let's say or woven and Shiraz or
designed in Shiraz and carpets are kind
of branded that way even by now by
families who who who produce these
carpets and home became an interesting
site for multiple reasons because it's a
religious city because it's an important
city now and it has national but
international significance things that
happen there have national international
significance but but also because homes
rug industry is the youngest and most
successful so what I was able to do was
able to do oral histories so just also
from my own father's family I knew that
they began in the 1930s and I started to
conduct oral histories and discovered
that the rug industry began and it's
sometime in the 1930s with a number of
young families who were forced to
migrate to the city for various reasons
but which a guy I go into the book but
but they were the original founders of
the rug industry in the
city of command because it was a
brand-new industry because there was no
history of it they were able to play
with designs and do all sorts of things
but it also allowed me to do the kind of
research that hadn't been done before
because there aren't really any
documents about rug merchants production
as much in terms of really anywhere else
in Iran and because this was a brand-new
industry I was able to still find folks
who were able to tell me and I started
to do this research in 1996 and so I
would go summers in an interview folks
who had just started who remembered
their their fathers or grandfather's and
sometimes themselves as they had moved
into the city to start the rug industry
and in doing the research for the book
what was the most surprising thing you
found well the most surprising thing
that I found was that being from a
merchant family didn't immediately give
me the access that I thought at the same
time it did at the same time I made
things very difficult because often
people thought I was trying to steal
designs for my own family and so I was I
was forced to prove myself in some ways
this that was probably one of the most
surprising things for me this this this
push to prove myself and once I was able
to prove myself I was able to have
access to rug merchants their private
lives that even my family did not know
about so it took a long time to gain
trust but I was able to do it in a way
that I thought well it was already
afforded to me because of my family but
but in fact because of my family
sometimes it was heavily guarded and I
was incredibly fascinated by the way rug
merchants and their their families were
so welcoming into their lives and it
would allow me to look through I was
interested in what they were reading for
example any sort of documents they would
have in their houses they they were open
to everything and so I got to
have a glimpse into their lives and I
was not as much surprised as I was
pleasantly in some ways rewarded by the
fact that I knew from a few family
friends that that women were very much
involved in every aspect of this
production sometimes behind the scene
team behind the scenes sometimes very
much in and the very forefront of it and
I was able to see that up front and and
personal and I was able to write about
it and so that became incredibly
rewarding and gratifying to know that it
is an it is a very much community base
and to be able to write about their
everyday experiences was really really
rewarding in that way I am curious you
have mentioned a couple of times that
families are hesitant to let people in
to see primarily the designs they're
doing for their cause now if because
it's secret when a rug comes out and
others see the design are there any like
a copyright two kinds of can no one else
create that kind of a rug once one
family has done it no they can and I
think part of the the problem well it's
it's not necessarily a problem for the
rest of the world but a problem for the
Iranian carpet merchants who believe
that carpets originated in in Iran
especially the modern carpet industry so
they're constantly battling global
competition and in in order to have
these copyright laws you would have to
have a powerful state that is respected
in the global international community
and of course the Islamic Republic of
Iran has had tense moments with many
folks in the world and so at the same
time even friends as well as foes I have
have sort of pushed the the carpet
industry in some ways to become
independent but if there the tension
lies where the merchants want to have an
independence independence in terms of
the carpet industry while the state
wants to control the carpet industry now
if you if they were to give power to the
state the state might be able to control
the copyright issues but again copyright
issues are incredibly difficult for for
anybody so rug merchants know that when
they commissioned a designer to come up
with a design they probably have at most
a year or two unless the design gets
stolen and then they have to come up
with new designs and these are sort of
high-end merchants so these are more
like sort of luxury boutique type
carpets so these are carpets that that
they know will only last for such a
short time so a carpet takes depends on
the size and the intricacies of its of
the details of the design but it takes
maybe about a year for it to be woven
and it takes about six months before
that to come up with a design the colors
and the scheme and so by the time the
color the carpet hits the market they
know that now they have to work on a new
design so the the the very best carpet
producers are at the forefront of making
sure they are coming up with new designs
which is very difficult and very arduous
and within your on there they're copying
their carpets but they're also copying
their carpets in India and Pakistan in
Egypt in Turkey in Morocco in China and
it used to be sometimes machine-made but
now they are making handmade Persian
carpets in China so it is incredibly
difficult to be able to tell except if
you have the expertise and that's the
other element in my book that comes out
is the way that these these carpet
merchants become experts in terms of
knowing what these rugs are and so if
you go into a carpet store anywhere you
see carpets are called Persian design
those often mean that they were probably
not made in Iran and and so again the
designs are copied from probably modern
or classic Persian carpet designs but
the fact that they weren't made in Iran
does that make it less or more of value
to the consumer it's less of a value for
sure because they expect it to be made
in Iran
I say thank you so much for being here
today and sharing some of your work
absolutely fascinating thank you for
more information about professor or
Romney enter research please visit our
website at Yale edu backslash Macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you